In this video we're going to focus on Markovnikov's rule.
So let's say we have this alkene, two pentene, and we react it with hydrobromic acid.
But we'll be the products of that reaction.
And let's compare it to if we have, let's say, one butane.
If we react that with HBR, we'll be the major product of that reaction.
Now for the first reaction above, we get a mixture of two different products.
We're going to get 3 bromo, pentane, and 2 bromo, pentane.
And this is going to be 50-50.
But for the reaction below, we're going to get a major product,
which is two bromo butane.
Now we could get one bromo butane, but that's going to be a minor product.
So the question is, why do we get this as the major product?
Well, there's something called more carbonicov's rule,
which basically states that the hydrogen atom or the electrophile adds to the carbon
with the most number of hydrogen atoms.
And these are the carbons that are the SB2 carbons.
The carbons that are part of the alkene.
So this, so here are the two SB2 carbons.
This carbon has one hydrogen, and this carbon has two hydrogen.
So based on more carbonicov's rule, the hydrogen is going to go on this carbon,
the one with the most number of carbons, which means the halogen goes on the other carbon.
So another way of looking at more carbonicov's rule is that the halogen,
the bromine atom is going to go on the more substituted carbon.
This carbon is primary because it's attached to only one other carbon.
This carbon is secondary because it's attached to two other carbon atoms.
So even though more complicated cause rules, they thought the electrophile,
in this case, hydrogen, goes on the SB2 carbon that has the greatest number of hydrogen atoms.
That rule is equivalent to saying that the halogen BR goes on the more substituted carbon atom.
And viewing it from that perspective will help you to find the answer quickly
and determine if the product is more carbonicov or anti-macarmicov.
So you can say this reaction proceeds with more carbonicov edition.
There are some reactions that proceed with anti-macarmicov edition.
Now the reaction on top is not regio selective.
So macarmicov's rule doesn't apply.
As you can see, both of these carbons are secondary and the bromine can go on either one of those two carbons.
But here there's a difference and so this reaction is going to be regio selective.
The bromine will preferentially, preferentially, add to the secondary carbon.
Now let's talk about the mechanism of this reaction.
To help us understand why the hydrogen atom goes on the primary carbon.
So the first thing that happens is the alkene that strikes a proton from HBR.
Now if we were to put the hydrogen on the secondary carbon, this will lead to a primary carbocation, which is not stable.
But if we were to put the hydrogen on the secondary, I mean on the primary carbon, this will lead to a secondary carbocation, which is more stable than a primary carbocation.
And that's the reason why the hydrogen atom goes on the less substituted carbon atom or the SB2 carbon with the most hydrogen atoms.
It's because it leads to a more stable carbocation intermediate.
Now the last step in this reaction is that bromide reacts with the carbocation, giving us the product to bromobutane.
So that's why this particular reaction proceeds with Marc Hartman-Card edition.
It's due to the fact that we get a more stable secondary carbocation intermediate.
Now consider the following through reactions.
Let's say the first one is mercury acetate with water followed by sodium borohydride.
And the second one is going to be hydroboration, oxidation.
And also we'll use HBR with peroxides.
And let's compare that to using just HBR by itself.
So the first reaction, oxymurceration, demurceration, that reaction proceeds with Marc Hartman-Card edition.
So we're going to add an OH group and it's going to go on the more substituted secondary carbone.
I mean the secondary carbon.
So this is going to be the product of this reaction.
Now the next reaction, hydroboration, oxidation with octane proceeds with anti Marc Hartman-Card edition.
So that means that the hydroxo group is going to go on the primary carbon or the less substituted carbon.
Of the two carbon atoms that are double-wonded.
Now we know that HBR proceeds with Marc Hartman-Card edition.
But HBR with peroxides proceeds with anti Marc Hartman-Card edition.
So it's important to know the VGEO selectivity of different reactions.
You need to know if a certain reaction proceeds with Marc Hartman-Card edition compared to if it was a carbon-card edition.
Now let's consider another example.
So let's say we have three methyl, one butine, and we're going to react it with some similar reagents.
The first one is going to be mercury acetate.
In water followed by sodium borohydride.
And then we're also going to use hydroboration, oxidation.
And then we're also going to react it with water under acidic conditions.
Or equivalently, let me say that again equivalently with H30+.
So the first reaction proceeds with Marc Hartman-Card edition just like before.
The OH group is going to go on a secondary carbon.
The second reaction proceeds with anti Marc Hartman-Card edition.
So the OH group is going to go on a primary carbon.
Now the third reaction is a little bit different.
And I want to compare the third reaction with the other starting out keen that we use in a previous example.
So if you were to mix one butine with H30+.
This reaction will proceed with Marc Hartman-Card edition.
If you were to mix H30+, or water and H30+, with this particular alkene.
The answer is different. You actually get an alcohol that looks like this.
The OH group doesn't go on a secondary carbon, but rather it goes on a tertiary carbon.
So you need to be careful with reactions that are that proceed with Marc Hartman-Card edition,
particularly the ones that are subject to rearrangements.
For the most part, the oxymorcharation demorcharation reaction doesn't generally proceed with rearrangements.
The major product is this product.
However, reactions that involve a carbocation intermediate, like the ones with HBR or HDO+,
these proceed with rearrangements.
And as a result, the OH group goes on the most substituted carbon,
that is in the vicinity of the double one.
So now let's go over the mechanism of that reaction.
Let's see why we get the tertiary alcohol.
So in the first step, we can react it with HDO+, or H+.
I'm going to use HDO+, the hydronium ion.
So the alkene is going to abstract a proton.
And we're going to get water.
Based on Marc Hartman-Card's role, that proton is going to go on the primary carbon,
the carbon with the most number of hydrogen atoms.
And now we're going to get a secondary carbocation.
Now tertiary carbocadines are more stable than secondary carbocadines.
And molecules and ions stay like to rearrange themselves to find the most stable configuration.
So a hydride shift will automatically occur.
And this is going to give us a tertiary, more stable carbocadine.
Once this tertiary carbocadine is formed, the water molecule that we got from the previous example,
I mean from the previous step, or any other water molecule that is available,
that's going to attack the carbocadine.
So once the nucleophile adds to the carbocadine center or the electrophile,
we're going to get this.
Next, we need to use another water molecule to remove a hydrogen from this pronated alcohol species,
or axonium species.
And then this will give us our final answer, where we have a tertiary alcohol.
So that's why we get that particular product.
It's due to a carbocadine via arrangement, and the driving force is stability.
Tertiary carbocadines are more stable, and then secondary carbocadines,
due to the inductive effect and hyperconjugation.
So that's it for this video.
Hopefully gave you a good introduction to Marc Haumekaw's role,
and how it works, and how it applies in these scenarios.
Thanks for watching.